there was screaming there was alarms
going off there was blood on the walls
these were places young people were sent
to by the NHS to make them better I can
see the wars I can smell it I can hear
it I can feel people on me
we've spoken to more than 20 former
patients of the huntercom group a
private company treating adolescents
with mental health problems and the
picture that's emerged is very
disturbing this isn't just the one-off
you've got young people who are coming
forward in their tens huntercom has a
new owner but the NHS is still paying
tens of millions of pounds a year for
the contract to care for huntercom's
vulnerable teenagers
I just don't think any place that
treated me like that should be open I
don't even know why they're still
running
I started struggling more with food and
eating
I started hurting myself and then I got
not very well physically and mentally
Amber was 15 when she went into a
children's mental health unit she's now
18.
she sometimes finds it hard to relax
played by flashbacks as a result of her
time there
I was suicidal before I went in but
before I went in I was thinking to make
a plan you know it was more like it's
going to happen once it's gonna work
when I got in every single thing I could
see that even slightly I could use I
would try and use because it was torture
being there there was a point where I
had where I made
three or four suicide attempts a day
some of them were extreme sometimes I'd
be going to a e I'd be using every
single thing around me do you think your
time in the unit helped you or not what
made things worse for you I don't feel
like they made me any better I think
they made me a lot worse
we've spent months chasing youngsters
across England who were cared for by a
single provider and Gathering their
testimonies
they all went to hospitals for 12 to 18
year olds run by the hanticum group two
of the group's units including this one
in maidenhead in Berkshire and another
in Staffordshire remain open three
others have been closed
for the first time we've Drawn Together
worrying evidence about the care given
by this provider Amber is one of a large
group of teenagers most of whom don't
know each other who we've spoken to for
this joint investigation with the
independent
Amber says some of her lowest moments
involved restraints which she was told
were to keep her safe or to enable
feeding her through a nasal tube there'd
be two people two grown adults Laying
across your leg one on either arm and
then someone on your head holding your
head in place and that's five grown
adults to one kid they'd hold you down
your crying screaming it would be
sometimes it would be painful and they
wouldn't listen when
I used to be restrained like people
would be holding me down for hours and
hours and hours I'd fall asleep
sometimes in it and sometimes then when
the restraints got too much then they
would just come in pull your trousers
down and IMU and I was iMed every day
what does that mean injection medication
so every single day and and it felt like
basically they were just sedating me
it's difficult for Amber's Family to
listen to her account but Amber's sister
Zara and her mother Nikki say they were
alarm Bells from day one
Nikki raised concerns about Amber's
treatment at maidenhead but was ignored
she filed an official Complaint which
led to an independent assessment of
Amber's care
the hanticum group admitted Amber into
its maidenhead unit in March 2019 she
was there for 14 months
an independent review into Amber's care
was published in 2021 the report has
been shared with Sky News it said there
was an over-reliance on physical
intervention and medication the use of
restraint was at times coercive and the
report recommended an urgent audit of
the use of restraint the way I describe
it for Amber is she went in kind of at
this level this is where we'd like her
to be she kind of went in here and she
ended up here and we are now just
bringing her back to where she started
we went through a living hell
you hand your child overthinking they're
going to get help and they're going to
get care
and the minute you realize that um
they're not getting that
um and more and worse than ever that
actually you can't do anything about it
but Amber's is not an isolated case just
a month before the report into Amber's
care Hunter come faced similar criticism
at the same unit over another teenager
who were calling Sally
an independent review into Sally's care
shared with Sky News found over Sally's
four-month stay she was restrained more
than 200 times it also recommended an
urgent audit into the use of restraint
we've been going back through the
reports of inspectors from the regulator
the Care Quality commission and found
repeated warnings about units run by the
huntercom group we've cross-referenced
these with the testimonies of the former
patients we've traced we have more than
20 statements verbal and written
accounts from former patients or their
relatives these were young girls at
Breaking Point with serious mental
health issues when they went into
Hospital needing specialist help
the people we've spoken to were in the
units over a 10-year period some as
recently as February and March this year
Lyra went into huntercom's hospitals
when she was just turning 14. she told
us on leaving their care I was more
mentally ill than when I was admitted
Danielle who was in the maidenhead unit
said I break down crying it affects me
every single day
Danny was in the Stafford unit for two
years for an eating disorder she told us
she was injured during restraints and
would often be left with bruising and
had her hair pulled out she shared these
pictures which she says are staff
sleeping when they should have been
monitoring at-risk patients
another teenager who wants to remain
anonymous said she was able to hide in a
corner of her room and self-harm without
staff noticing her arm bleeding
the sister of another patient said each
time she visited her sister appeared
more and more drugged up to the point at
times she could hardly communicate
Nema was groomed during her stay at
Hunter comes Whatcom Hall Hospital in
Devon which has now closed she told us
she was subjected to countless Horrors
and staff were cold and cruel she said
after leaving I had to learn to live
again
all these teenagers say they were failed
by the care they received
but for years the hanticum group has
been aware of the serious criticisms
it's faced in 2014 it was sued by
Natasha Beauchamp for failing to provide
appropriate psychiatric treatment
in 2017 the regulator the Care Quality
commission raised concerns about
Staffing observations and how to put
Lessons Learned into practice at all its
sites in the same year
seventeen-year-old Mia tetherage took
her own life at the Norwich unit as
subsequent inquest said she wasn't
properly checked
a year and a half after Mia's death a
teenager went into the group's
maidenhead unit who were calling Jane
Jane wants to remain anonymous broke me
made things worse and I don't think I'm
the only one we're not showing Jane's
face or her mother's but they've agreed
for their voices to be used Jane went
into the maidenhead unit with autism and
low-level self-harming when she was 14.
there was another visitor room
and that's the one that we were mostly
taken to it was a place Jane's mother
says she came to know well everything
about that time remains Vivid for both
of them Jane is now 18.
such a horrible place that people resort
to such
horrible things when I walked in there's
blood all over the walls and people just
literally whack their head against the
wall Jane's mother kept her diary of her
visits to the maidenhead unit I saw the
children whacking their heads I saw a
child kneeing herself in the face I saw
a young man I can only describe him as a
young man he didn't look like a child
masturbating in the middle of the
corridor it's like what you read about
asylums and work houses the clear trauma
and pain and suffering and they were
children and they were treated worse
than animals Jane's care was examined in
a subsequent independent review shared
with Sky News and concluded there was
little offered in terms of actual
treatment it described the unit as a
dark space that had an oppressive feel I
just get flashbacks
of what it looks like
like what it smelled like
just
what it like felt like and just and then
obviously the individual things that
happen whilst you're there but just the
whole thing
again and again former patients told us
the hospitals were places where they
felt they wouldn't get better
I knew the moment I arrived there it
wasn't the right place for me
those screaming there was alarms going
off there was blood on the walls it was
yeah it was pretty bad it's a year now
since Alice left maidenhead she went in
at the age of 16 she says in crisis
severely self-harming and with an eating
disorder you sprained your wrist in your
ankle yeah yeah because they weren't
holding me correctly yeah
another former patient complaining not
just about the techniques used to stop
herself harming but detailing how she
felt the environment put her at even
greater risk often a lot of other
patients were using different
self-harming methods it's staff often
didn't let didn't stop them from doing
that so they'd do it in like communal
areas and I would learn new ways to do
to self-harm I think it's awful I just
don't think that
any place like that that treated me like
that should be open I don't even know
why they're still running
when you read these testimonies what do
you make of them you know there's
references here to Blood on the walls
describing treatment that sounds
barbaric we showed our findings to Anne
Longfield the former children's
commissioner who's now chairing an
independent review of inpatient mental
health care the CQC really does need to
take this seriously and needs to visit
at speed to ensure they get an
understanding of what's going on there
Sky News can reveal NHS England has paid
nearly 190 million pounds to run
Children's Mental Health Services at a
number of huntercom sites since 2015.
the kind of eye-watering thumbs that
we're given to Providers to provide
Specialist Care clearly what what what
you're showing here is that that was
making some children much worse on every
level that's not something that's
acceptable at Active Care Group we
strive to ensure our patients residents
and clients are kept safe in December
2021 the hanticum group was taken over
by Active Care Group which told us it
has robust processes in place Dr Sylvia
Tang has been the CEO since June 2020 a
year and a half before the merger
in a statement she said at the time most
of these incidents are alleged to have
taken place the Active Care Group did
not own the facilities at which they are
purported to have happened the previous
owners retain all the legal entities and
Associated records for these facilities
prior to their acquisition the current
group is therefore unable to comment on
the services provided prior to this date
even so we are very saddened and
concerned to hear about these patient
experiences
the previous owners Ellie Investments
said it regrets the hospitals which were
independently managed failed to meet the
expected standards for high quality Care
in February this year two months after
the acquisition of the hanticum group by
Active Care Group a patient at the unit
in maidenhead now called taplo Manor
died what happened is now the subject of
an investigation by Thames Valley police
and the CQC
Active Care Group says the death of a
young person at taplo Manor in February
2022 was a tragic and sad event we have
already taken steps to make improvements
to the service and remain committed to
providing the best possible care for our
patients
the NHS is currently paying for nearly a
hundred beds at the huntercom units now
owned by Active Care Group maidenhead is
rated as requiring Improvement and
Staffordshire inadequate
an NHS spokesperson said all services
must provide safe high quality care and
deliver on the commitments in their
contracts the CQC said Active Care Group
is subject to close and ongoing
monitoring where we find issues we have
taken and continue to take decisive
action
friends come here Amber is one of a
number of former patients we spoke to
for whom their time at huntercom's
maidenhead unit contributed to a formal
diagnosis of post-traumatic stress
disorder
even when I'm out with my friends it
comes up in every conversation
even though it's so much over it's not
at all because it ruined my life
sometimes
I'll just be normally sat here and I can
look around and I'm there again I can
see the walls I can smell it I can hear
it I can feel people on me I can feel
people holding me and it's horrible it
happens a lot and it hasn't stopped
every day guaranteed that it's been
going through my head more than anything
else
which is messed up because I just want
to move on
in response to our report the Department
of Health told us the allegations of
mistreatment raised by Sky News are
deeply concerning it's now working with
NHS England and the CQC to investigate